this situation i'm able to sink my body
back and get my hands in front now
important part to pay attention to here
is i'm not trying to pull my arms
forward if mike's really strong and i
pull i'll never get there but with the
same amount of force if i move my butt
back instead you see how my hands
instantly get in front of my body so
instead of trying to pull my forward i
simply let myself sink into the space
between us
as i do this i express cocciate in my
hands and i push my elbows down this
brings his elbows up puts me in a strong
position in him in a weak position i use
this position to slide myself underneath
his arm here the eq is immediately
available to me instead of trying
anything fancy i'm just going to shove
it away since this makes ikio nagam use
the eco to throw him away from me
one more time to speak
bushiro ryotedori ionage